North Korea now says it may call off Kim
jong-un's meeting with President Trump
over US demands to denuclearize the
Korean Peninsula
North Korea's first vice minister of
foreign affairs said in statement
overnight quote if the United States is
trying to drive us into a corner to
force our unilateral nuclear abandonment
this country would have to quote
reconsider our proceeding to the North
Korea u.s. summit Ben Tracy is following
developments from Beijing Ben good
morning good morning so that summit is
supposed to happen next month in
Singapore but now North Korea says it
may not happen at all if the US doesn't
stop insisting that it completely
denuclearize North Korea is warning that
there is a limit to what it calls its
goodwill
North Korea says the United States
should not confuse its openness to
getting rid of its nuclear weapons for a
sign of weakness president Trump's
National Security Advisor John Bolton
was singled out by the North Koreans for
suggesting on Face the Nation that North
Korea could be disarmed like Libya
fifteen years ago but is it a
requirement that Kim jong-un agreed to
give away those weapons before you give
any kind of concession I think that's
right I think we're looking at the Libya
model of 2003-2004 North Korea's first
vice minister of foreign affairs said
it's absolutely absurd to dare compare
the DPRK a nuclear weapons state to
Libya
adding on Bolton we do not hide our
feeling of repugnance toward him but one
thing that Libya did that led us to
overcome our skepticism was that they
allowed American and British observers
into all their nuclear related sites the
North Koreans don't appreciate the Libya
example because eight years after
dictator Muammar Qaddafi abandoned his
weapons development he was overthrown
and killed but unlike Libya North Korea
already possesses a number of nuclear
weapons and has threatened to use them
our ask is complete and total
denuclearization the administration's
demand for irreversible denuclearization
without direct economic aid from the US
also appears to have suddenly earth the
North Koreans who call the u.s. rhetoric
reckless and sinister
but the regime does appear to still be
following through on its promise to
destroy its main nuclear testing site
new satellite images shows several
buildings at the site have been torn
down North Korea abruptly pulled out of
a meeting with South Korea today at the
DMZ saying it's upset about ongoing
military exercises being conducted by
the South Koreans and the United States
now all of this could just be a
negotiating ploy by the North Koreans
going into this summit with President
Trump trying to remind the world that
North Korea is not going to be pushed
around Ben Tracy in Beijing thank you